this should have been match day in Bari
the pitch has been maintained in hope
but there will be no match after 134
years of existence
bari FC is close to death big clubs
including Manchester United feared
giggling and the white shirts of Bari at
the turn of the 20th century the team
won the famous FA Cup twice while the
big clubs got bigger Barry couldn't keep
up chairman tried but over stretched
themselves a familiar tale in modern
football the controversial owner during
the liquidation process Steve Dale has
stayed away from the town the people of
Bari are angry with him and at the
English Football League for expelling
them but mainly they are heartbroken
we're almost grieving together and going
through something and we're remembering
all the good times and we're getting
upset but then we're also laughing and
so that's something I like about burying
about especially sort of grassroots
football is you're not going to win
every week
Zoe Hitchens staged an exhibition of
Bari memorabilia in Manchester there is
no shortage of precious memories in the
town Azuri to collect Carl grind rod had
given 40 years of support it's
heartbreaking for every one of us really
is Barry's got a big strong community
about it you know as I thought well club
so everything's missing now unlocking in
it the old football the old town is lost
really without pot well we were as big
as months it seemed an United them there
so we've actually been a big club the
ice they were scoring an FA Cup final
six nil against Derby County it's too
much money nowadays it's not a sport
anymore is it it's just a business and
that's it
barrier one of many English clubs who've
had severe financial problems ten
kilometers away matchday a Bolton
Wanderers survivors one of English
football's glorious old clubs they
nearly went out of business just a few
months ago while Barry were kicked out
of the Football League Bolton were
punished with points deducted but they
were rescued when a buyer intervened
just in time there's just something
about match day the sounds the sights
the smells
for both Wanderers fans it's been part
of life for over 140 years it's
something that can't just be taken away
from people
mark Isles reported on Bolton and Barry
in crisis the first chairman Stuart day
bad decisions left him with a lot of
debt second Chairman Steve Dale I don't
think his soul was invested in the place
and I don't think he was there for the
right reasons the AFL is meant to have
control over both of those people being
able to run a football club for me they
lost control over both of those men
football has got to be protected and in
clubs like Barry have got to be
protected in the future because once
they're gone they're gone Peterborough
were meant to be Barry's opposition in
Ligue 1 on this particular Saturday
nothing special but it would have meant
something joy Hart encapsulate Sperry
football her father les was a player
here and physio and manager she had
raised awareness of their plight by
handcuffing herself to the club it means
it's the greater football community
we're all we felt a mourning over the
town name definitely it's a death and
generations it will affect you have to
be a football supporter really to
understand that if they're thinking
about us they know the death that we
feel over in Bolton they score late to
win their match
they always do it the hard way Mustaine
oh very good yeah just what we needed
I see my do evening Oh shame about
rebels they have to get back in there to
bury fans just want their matchday back
Lee Wellings al-jazeera in the town of
Barry